welcome to this video playing FM momento
yeah i'm going to play the video on do
something else happen for a change of
pace what is he going for Bishop c4 is
what they play mostly there's also this
crazy G form which I don't know anything
about okay so something conventional
that's good
my ideas to play b5 later so going for
this 6-ranked setup let's get this going
out of the D foul 11 advantage of this
kind of setup like the philidor is that
it's almost identical regardless what
what why this doing and this makes it a
good weapon for blitz chess you can
quickly play those moves and yes I might
lose a little bit of a little bit of
let's say equity hinder in the position
here and there because I'm playing a
chord playing quickly miss little things
but you still have a quite solid
position like yeah this cannot possibly
bad relief for black 96-94 s my idea and
they have spent no time that's good so
yeah maybe just stroke 28 let's get
let's get the hooks traded he has taken
some time to put them on the D phone
probably you won't take but still it can
promote that
for once I'm clearly head on the clock
yeah it's really a benefit of those some
more set up based openings I think it is
just basically an equal position no it's
not equal no I think I'm fine because he
weakened f4 quite a bit I'm really not
sure why why would you give me their
fourth square here curious okay so take
him now what now like to get rid of the
night but
not sure about this so I'm going to put
it here like g6 he can could have gone
to age 60 I can it's better probably to
prepare this thing is 92 actually
probably getting rid of the night
quickly okay
let's reboot see 5 is 6 if possible yeah
I'm taking e 2 looks pretty ridiculous
here a g2 I mean looks pretty ridiculous
Charlie checking down I really want to
have the bishops but here Bishop 1g2
looks like a really bad pizza ha that's
an interesting question ok let's do that
I don't see something coming to g5 so
opening up here this this diagonal
shouldn't be a bad a bad thing and a5 a4
as an additional idea
yeah activating the bishop okay should
deform yeah maybe invest this month and
this investors move c3 looks ugly so and
the bishop trade is definitely welcome
okay you voided the trade i have a five
though a 5v form yeah let's go them
at the time the time will be a factor
here so let's see push-ups III don't
know don't know really
queen is 26 a move known did go for that
here I thought just 94 but it's not
clear that this helps me I can also play
g6 to ask him about this night yeah come
on if he goes to age 6 it's not so clear
this is a good square okay he goes back
95 Bishop a 60 90 form
and thank you for should be okay so to
activate this fish Upon A to A six
somehow or just be should be to
attacking yeah let's do that maybe just
to take the seat upon keep the keep the
bishops
no nice position mean b6 Bishop a six
maybe time warning okay mmm it's this
draw is this a draw like a cheek don't
know someone at scene 48 for him
yeah much room can I win this b3 is the
symbol
here for Queen a two or something for
Queen B 1 check checkmate yeah what was
I didn't even see that his main I just
wanted to promote this yeah i was always
pressing there for quite a long for
quite a long while but i couldn't really
make it it wasn't so clear yeah maybe it
was wrong to to play with before them it
it keeps my my advantages they are very
permanent but it's not it's not clear
this is the best way forward them like
him it's very nice but maybe if I don't
yeah well played out yeah I always kept
kept the pressure on them in there in
the game so I think it's it was ok but
maybe there was something something
better long long the way you know I
could have taken you far better but by
now she didn't even didn't have any any
time on the clock yeah this supposed to
make him missing things and see to also
but check [ __ ] all of a sudden all of a
sudden it wasn't made yeah the the
problem here in this game was when he
came here around here so relatively it's
a symmetrical situation but it's some
difficult for him to make any headway
and it's a thing
equal ish but ok for me and then he went
g4 which is mostly weakening squares and
didn't didn't really didn't really help
him in some way so I felt this is very
very comfortable ok well thanks for
watching